The Kremlin
pushing back on newly declassified U.S.
intelligence that shows 20,000
Russian soldiers have been killed
in Ukraine since December alone.
A large portion of
those are likely
private Virginia
mercenary fighters
killed around the area of Buck Mount,
where you see these apocalyptic scenes
we're showing you right now.
Despite the total destruction, Ukraine
says Russia has not completely captured
the eastern city.
Now largely a symbolic goal
rather than a strategic one.
CNN's Nick
Paton Walsh is in the southern city
of Zappa,
Russia, Ukraine, for us right now.
And Nick,
British intelligence
you say, shows
Russia is afraid
Ukraine could achieve a, quote,
major breakthrough.
They're building up
an extensive system of trenches
in the south.
Tell us what you're seeing
you know,
there has been an extraordinary network
dug possibly,
according to this British
intelligence report,
the largest we've seen since World
War Two.
Across the southern area of Zacharia,
we've driven along
the Ukrainian side of it for quite a past
number of weeks here.
Often, these are deep trenches,
followed by a significant sandbank
backed up with razor wire.
And then these dragon's
teeth sort of pyramid
shaped pieces of concrete
that form
a complex series of defenses,
not insurmountable
with modern
weaponry and explosives
and targeted missiles at all.
But certainly a challenge
that will be very much
in the mind
of Ukrainian forces
as they probably in the days ahead,
if not already in the days
behind begin
the counter offensive in these areas.
We simply don't know
the full details
of their plan, to be honest,
and whether it's
potentially playing into it.
There's been an extraordinary
lack of videos
from Ukrainian military
over the past weeks.
They normally post from the front,
but those we have seen
have talked
about the mud
slowing down their capacity
to move around the battlefield.
All, frankly, that would be advertised.
But we've also heard
from the Ukrainian ambassador
to the United Kingdom
that, in fact,
this bad weather is playing a part,
but sunny one day, rainy the next.
All of this plays into the broader issue
here, Jake.
And we are, of course, also hearing
from around the city of Parma,
so deeply symbolic that Russian forces
there are expressing concerns
about a lack of artillery shells
and the possibility that might mean
they have to start pulling back Jake.
And Nick,
we're also hearing
about increased attacks
and sabotage
in occupied areas in the south.
Tell us about that
Yes, certainly building up
this broader
anticipation of the counteroffensive.
A number of attacks,
what you might refer to
as in occupied
areas behind enemy
lines, particularly in Malaita,
a key target city
for Ukraine
to liberate in the weeks ahead.
A few days ago,
we heard of a police official
there that was working for the Russian
occupying forces
He was killed,
according to sources there.
And in the last hours or so,
we've heard of another attempt
to target an official
working for the occupying Russian forces
there as well.
On top of that two
now, a number of explosions
in Brian's
targeting rail facilities in that area.
One may have been an improvised
explosive device, suggestions
of another potential explosion
just today.
So increasingly, as we head
into what many believe
is now the beginning
of Ukraine's counteroffensive,
something there have been
absolutely clear they will not announce.
We are seeing more sabotage of targets
inside occupied areas Jake.
All right.
Nick Paton Walsh in Zappa, Russia,
Ukraine for us. Thank you so much. Today.
Some rare praise from the White House
for Republican House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
after McCarthy
pushed back on a Russian reporter
who asked him about, quote,
not supporting
unlimited aid to Ukraine
during McCarthy's trip to Israel.
Take a listen.
I vote for aid for Ukraine.
I support aid for Ukraine.
I do not support
what your country has done
you do to Ukraine.
I do not support
your killing of the children. Either.
And I think for one standpoint,
you should pull out.
And I don't think it's right.
This after McCarthy repeatedly
said there would be, quote,
no blank check to Ukraine
from his Republican majority
House of Representatives.
White House Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre said
she was glad to hear
McCarthy swat down
that Russian propaganda.
US Secretary of State
Antony Blinken admitted that U.S.
dialog with Russia is, quote, irregular
when it comes to Americans
detained there.
As families
and advocacy groups
continue to push the Biden administration
for more action
The Bring Our Families
Home campaign will hold a vigil
in Washington, D.C.
this evening to implore President Biden
and his administration to do more
to bring wrongfully detained Americans
held hostage all over the world home.
Ahead of the event,
a billboard
truck circled the White House
and State Department
displaying messages
such as
protest that the president
of the United States stop ignoring us.
One of the attendees
at tonight's vigil, U.S.
Marine veteran
detained in Russia
for nearly three years,
Trevor Reed, Trevor
and his parents, Joey and Paula Reid,
joins us now.
And I think our viewers know
you guys by now,
although we're all keeping up
with your various looks.
First, you got huge
and now you got the beard.
Trevor, before we get to
tonight's vigil, for for over a year
I'm sorry, just over a year ago,
you were released
from the Russian prison.
I want to play a part of our conversation
last May
when they told me that I was leaving.
I thought that Paul, you know,
was leaving with me
and when I found out that they left him
here,
that was tough.
You didn't want to go with him.
You didn't have a choice.
Trevor
sorry.
You didn't have a choice.
There's nothing you could do
Yeah,
I realize that, but
the fact is that
the United States
should have got him out,
and we have to get there now at any cost.
First, of all,
I have to say, the fact that you got out
and that you and
your family are as involved
still on trying to get other people
out is just remarkable.
And such a testament
to the character of your family.
But here we are
a year later, Paul Wieland still there.
Now, another American,
Wall Street Journal reporter, Evan
Miscovich, is there.
If you could speak right now
directly to them,
what would you say to those two men?
I would tell them that
they have to hold on and that,
you know, we're fighting here
and we're not going to stop
until they come home
and to not give up
and to keep making noise.
How are you doing?
It's been a year.
You've been out of prison.
How's everything?
I'm doing really well.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it takes a couple
of months to kind of adjust.
But then after that,
you just kind of go back
to doing what you were before and
and fitting back into things.
So that's good.
Well, you look great.
And your parents
look ten years
younger than last time I saw them.
Oh, that's the makeup.
No, it's not.
So Joey and Paula
the Bring Our Family's Home campaigns
vigil and rallies.
Goal is to get President Biden
to meet
with the detained American families
and not just the ones
that are,
quote unquote, famous,
not just the ones that are notable.
I want to play a part of lead U.S.
hostage envoy Roger Carstens.
On Christiane Amanpour Show.
When asked
why Biden wouldn't meet with families
of less
famous detained Americans, take a look
we've brought back
27 Americans in 27 months of that number.
Only two of those families met
with the president.
So there were 25 Americans
that were brought home in the last over
two years
whose families never met
with the president of the United States.
The real measure of success
is whether someone comes home
stops on the tarmac on U.S.
soil and falls
into the loving arms of their family.
That's the metric
that we're shooting for.
And I know
you you love Roger Carstens,
and he's he's an American hero.
Did this job for Trump
doing it with Biden.
All praise to him at the time.
We should know
your family was the only family.
Other detainee held in Russia
to have met with President Biden.
Do you think that actually made
a difference?
There's no doubt
there's
we said for a year and a half
before that meeting.
We just need to get through
the bureaucracy
to the man who makes the decisions.
And once he hears
about our son personally
and what he's going through,
that he will make it happen.
And 27 days later, Trevor was a free man.
And you heard President Biden
the other night saying something,
talking about this issue. Right.
And the thing was, like you said,
a more famous people or whatever,
we weren't famous.
We're just regular people.
But I think it was
because we just never let up
and we just kept going
and going and going.
And then after that happened
and because the president
is a compassionate person,
he could see the pain
in our family's eyes
from not having Trevor with us.
And he decided to do something about it.
So you think it made a difference?
Do you think it was a difference
between President Biden saying, well,
I don't know about that swap
and President Biden saying,
just do this for the. Absolutely.
Yeah, it was
it was a combination of things,
but absolutely
there is
that personal,
personal issue,
you know, with the president wanting
wanting to do the right thing.
And we also we're here
to employ the president
to meet with the families,
especially the ones
that are here in town.
I mean, he can meet with the group.
And it would be
it would be
even though it would not be individual.
But at least
even if they just had a minute
or two with the president
so he could put a face with the name.
And it would be a great thing
for the president.
I know he'd love to do it.
And, you know,
it would help him politically if nothing
else, but.
Trevor, you told me last year
that you thought
before you travel to Russia,
there was no way that Russia would detain
another American like
they had Paul Wieland,
and that would make Russia, you know?
Now they've done it again
with Chris Kovac.
You said it would make Russia
like North Korea.
In your words,
it is no American safe in Russia,
do you think? No.
I mean, when I said that things
with Russia
hadn't really escalated to the point
that they're out now,
but I think that it's
you know, extremely clear that
that right now
any American that travels to Russia
is in grave danger of of being
taken hostage
by by Russia, of
being wrongfully detained.
And I think that
that amount of desperation
that the Russians have right now
is going to continue to mount
until eventually,
maybe even diplomats
are going to be at risk of that.
So what we're going to continue
to cover the story
of all those Americans held
and detained unfairly, unjustly abroad.
And honestly,
you three are
you're one of the reasons
that we all continue to do it.
So thank you so much.
Thank you for continuing to do it,
because it means a lot to the family.
We couldn't have done what we did
without people like you.
Well, though,
I guess
I'm just glad that you get to get him
to kiss. Yes, I do.
Trevor, Joey and Paula, thanks so much.
Coming.